I do feel like as a society we don't
give weird people enough credit
um
like
we always act like weird people are
happening to us
I'm guilty of it too I live in New York
maybe one day I have to go to a
high-rise there's too many flights of
stairs to take it up so I take the
elevator and there's only one other dude
on the elevator
and he weird
and then I get in and I hit 19 on the
elevator and he hits 20 I'm like this
about to be a journey all right
but I'm trying to be more empathetic
because
because like I think truly that all of
us no matter who you are we're all doing
the best we can with what we have
everybody
it's not an excuse sometimes that's very
sad sometimes like that's your best I
don't know
but it's true we're all doing our best
as much as we can which means when you
meet a weird person they could have been
weirder
you know like maybe they did walk up to
you just start talking about fish and
stuff like that but they could have
walked up like
thank you
I'm also trying to be more empathetic
because I'm weird
I'm like a weird guy
you know like if we hung out after this
you'd be like he off like
it's a thing that I know about myself
I'll give you my best example I usually
work at a grocery store and when I
worked there I worked with a guy who's
very weird
like deeply
it was never malicious but it was always
very weird
like he would just
microwave fish in the break room
and then eat it in front of all of us
like he wasn't a terrorist
and so then I became his friend because
I've never been more sure someone was
going to shoot up a store
then when I saw him hit five minutes on
some Atlantic salmon I'm like he
probably got that gun on him right now
I gotta play my cars right
because in my mind if we're friends that
means the day he shoots up the story
he's gonna be like Josh get out of here
like all right my man okay
I told you I should have been nice to
him that's all y'all
and so we become friends genuine friends
and then one day he calls me and he's
like hey Josh I would love for you to
come have dinner with me and my family
which I was very excited about
because if we're out here having dinners
together that means he gonna call me the
day before he shoot up
[Applause]
I'm like Josh don't come in Thursday
it's going down
so I I rolled to the house and I'm
willing to be wrong I am but to my
knowledge there's only two handshakes
that you use to greet people
all right there's a traditional
handshake
open pump and then there's the fist bump
hey how you doing
this man opened the door look me in my
eyes extended his arm and didn't do
either one he just did this what is this
what is this what the hell is happening
right now
[Applause]
I've ever seen all right you can't even
high five this you'll miss what is this
this is absolute insanity this is not a
handshake this is how you feed a horse
when you're scared
what is this and I know what to do but I
don't want to be rude and so I just
pinched it like a crab on the side
and started going up and down like that
here's the thing the social contract
with the pounds that's a moment in time
you know it's a hey what's up what's
good with you how you doing right the
social contract with a handshake is that
we both extend our hand we give each
other a firm grip and then when you
start to let go I know to let go right
but because this is nothing but let go I
don't know when to let go
so I'm just doing this for what feels
like a day and he's just taking it he's
just letting me do it he's like and yes
this is right
this pleases me
and I'm not gonna lie maybe see my
friend in an entirely different light
because when this is your dad
maybe Mike Williams some fish isn't that
crazy Maybe
he's just doing the best he can with
what he has